наразі немає діалогу і порозуміння з
керівництвом коли УПЦ МП залишить
територію Лаври спитайте у пацієнта це
три щонайменше три шари діалог закони
воюємо з наших ідентичність нашу
спадщину за нашу мову літературу історію
чому Міністерство культури не збирало
кошти на дрони а їм Sorry very much ну
кожен займається своєю справою Давайте
тоді визначимося суспільством що
зберігати українську спадщину історію
під час війни ми не будемо не будемо
паритися тоді
міністр культури та інформаційної
політики Олександр Ткаченко сьогодні в
інтерв'ю Deutsche Welle українською п
Олександре Вітаю вас Дякую що погодилися
на цю розмову Добрий день найперших хочу
почати із важливого питання релігійного
церковного воно нас актуальне останні
півроку як каже президент Зеленський це
питання нашої духовної Незалежності і
один із ключових напрямків діяльності
мінкульту зараз якщо я правильно розумію
найперше ми будемо говорити про УПЦ
представники якої протестують коли їх
називають церквою Московського
патріархату вони кажуть що ще в травні
22-го року вони відмежувалися від Росії
вони стали незалежною від Росії церкви
Вони сказали що не мають нічого
спільного з патріархом Кирилом чи є УПЦ
незалежною від Росії Української церкви
по-перше хотів би внести ясність
питаннями релігії в сьогодні опікується
державне агентство з питань Етна
політики та свободи совісті ми дотичні
до цього питання в сенсі
управління об'єктами культурної спадщини
які частково використовуються різним
релігійними організаціями
стосовно питання назвою УПЦ МП чи УПЦ
формально так УПЦ і навіть я довільний
називав їх УПЦ з формальною точки зору
але на жаль перебіг війни та дії
багатьох очільників
цієї церкви священиків які вступали в
колаборацію підтримувала агресію На жаль
показало що
представники цієї церкви не втратило
зв'язки з Москвою
інакше ніж розставити картки Нади і
називати те що є по факту справді
Московським патріархатом Я не вбачаю в
цьому проблема це насправді так і є тому
що їхні духовний центр знаходиться в
Москві коли в останнє представники
міністерства культури
зустрічалися з митрополитом онуфрієм
Я здається
[музика]
чи двічі здається зустрічався на початку
воєнних дій коли від УПЦ МП не було чути
чітких меседжів стосовно їхнього розриву
з Росією і їхньої чіткої позиції так
Митрополита Онуфрій засудив військові
дії але жодних акцентів з приводу того
що все це саме власне Росія
з приводу розриву відносин з російським
патріархатом з приводу
взаємодії можливої з пцу з приводу
спільних служінь з приводу не згадування
крила
в своїх молитвах наразі на той момент не
було І зовсім і ці розмови ми проводили
як приватні бесіди тому що держава не
може Втручатися в діяльність
релігійних організаціях але в мене як у
громадянина виникало запитання
на жаль на жодне з них я чітковою
відповіді не отримав натомість були
закиди на адресу пцу традиційні і
наша спроба свого часу здається влітку
Минулого року організувати круглий стіл
за участі представників УПЦ Іп пцу
завершилася
тим що вона була успішною всі учасники
сказали що це дуже корисний досвід
налагодження діалогу а не але в
подальшому
прийшла пряма заборона представникам УПЦ
брати участь в подальших круглих столах
тобто
можливість діалогу була призупинена
самими представниками упцмента
якісь наслідки від цього круглого столу
від цієї зустрічі були це пам'ятаю було
в липні Минулого року здається в Софії
Київській дійсно там була декларація
ухвалена все виглядала дуже позитивно і
ви тоді говорили що це ось початок шляху
до якогось діалогу якісь наслідки
все-таки були можливо для частини
духовенства УПЦ напевно були якби діалог
був продовжуний тобто сам факт того що
він можливо говорить про те що
зміна позиції УПЦ МП на діалог на
знаходження єдності в рамках
українського суспільства відсутня але
вона насправді є у багатьох священиків
таке бажання Тобто це на мій погляд
політична позиція
захисту московських інтересів в Україні
тобто з керівництвом УПЦ питання Лаври
ви Особисто не обговорювали це
обговорюють представниками монастиря
представники заповідника Я знаю що з
ними спілкувався пан єленський там був
якийсь обмін листами з приводу того що
потрібно було б УПЦ МП чіткіше висловити
свою позицію стосовно
їхнього так би мовити
Ага координації дій з Москвою чи
підпорядкування мозкової але натомість
жодного рішення не прийнято Я думаю що
тут на часі нарешті прийняття закону
Який давно внесений урядом на стосовно
визнання нечинними дій релігійних
організацій які зберігають зв'язки з
центрами управління в державі-агресорі
причому хочу зауважити що це мова йде в
проекті цього закону не про УПЦ МП А
взагалі про всі релігійні організації
якщо в них
центр Може знаходитися в Москві це тобто
заборона таких релігійних організацій
фактично
закону який е-е дає можливості в
подальшому
робити певні дії державному Державній
Службі та свободи совісті
стосовно реєстрації на реєстрації цих
релігійних організацій на території
України ви підтримуєте той Урядовий
законопроект який внесений до Ради але
не розглядається зараз
Ну в принципі найближчим часом буде
розглядатися Я думаю що закон дуже
корисний Як ви думаєте чому досі його не
розгля отримали бо він здається ще Ну з
квітня точно Ні навіть з лютого якщо не
помиляюсь А головне щоб розглянули Я
сподіваюсь що це станеться найближчим
часом
і принаймні В мене є підстави так про це
говорити Чи є у вас якась надія на
поновлення діалогу між УПЦ і пцу
з боку пцу завжди були відкриті так би
мовити двері для діалогу пропонувалися
спільній богослужіння
і інші ініціативи але
натомість з боку УПЦ завжди в першу
чергу виникало запитання з приводу
начебто не канонічності пцу
із приводу інших закидів щодо переходів
е-е
громад з УПЦ МП в пцу Ну там є певний
набір так би мовити претензій Що
унеможливлювало такий діалог насправді
між священиками на рівні
монахів простих такий діалог в приватний
триває і той факт що була був хоч образ
але цей круглий стіл говорить про те що
він можливий але натомість позиція
керівництва пцмп не дозволяється не
дозволяється зробити зараз дуже важливу
роль відіграє капеланство чи є
представники УПЦ МП як капелани в зоні
бойових дій Наскільки я знаю Деякі
представники УПЦ МП в
капеланстві знаходяться сьогодні в Лаврі
це якраз з точки зору оновлення про
осмислення ролі києво-печерської Лаври
капелани
будуть знаходитися на реабілітації в на
території Лаври впродовж тижня здається
там передбачені певні
в тому числі не тільки екскурсія але
бесіди розмови артистичні
так би мовити заняття і в межах нашого
нового уявлення про те якою має бути цей
центр культурного і духовного
культурної духовної
життя в Україні в Лаврі Ми намагаємося
відродити там і екскурсії нормальні так
Щоб був доступ до нижньої Лаври вводимо
як квиток там відбувається
пастерні співи це багато оголосію
традиційне українське е-е середини
вірніше середньовічне і є багато інших
планів стосовно того що була вра не жила
в двох різних світах свій нижньої Лаври
світ верхньої Лаври і ми чуємо багато
відгуків від відвідувачів Лаври що їм
набагато приємніше зараз приходити в
лавру ніж це було раніше ви говорите
зараз про нижню лавру про центр для
реабілітації капеланів поки що центр
реабілітації знаходиться верхня Лаврі
але це одні з ініціатив які заплановані
на цей рік
з приводу капеланів у Державній Службі з
однополітики свободи совісті говорили що
представники УПЦ МП не можуть бути
кпоганами
Я не володію точною інформацією я знаю
що УПЦ МП заявляє про те що вони там є Я
особисто не бачив можуть тільки з розмов
їхніх цитат говорити про це але з вашої
особистої точки зору чи доречно щоб
представники УПЦ МП як капелани
працювали з військовими Я думаю що в
першу чергу потрібно визначитися зі
статусом УПЦ МП
а а всі рішення інші мають приймати
командири ну тобто це відання не
Міністерство культури чи навіть де суд -
це віддання власне
командирів які приймають рішення коли
СБУ проводило обшуки в Лаврі управління
верховного комісара ООН людини випустила
доповідь у якій висловили занепокоєння
що такі дії Ось такі офіційні дії проти
УПЦ можуть бути дискримінаційними що ви
на це скажете
[музика]
люди які належать до релігійних
організацій є громадянами України якщо
вони порушують закон якщо в них в їхніх
діях є ознаки колаборації чи сприяння
російської агресії якщо порушення закону
щодо управління майном якщо є якісь
новобудови на території пам'ятки Юнеско
якщо я перешкоджання діяльності
комісії мінкульту
так би мовити
виключень бути не може це не
благословіння
Боже порушувати українські закони це
порушення українських законів
крім он ще Папа Римський був дуже
занепокоєний з того приводу що майну
Лаври
забирають УПЦ він теж висловлював
заклики поважати релігійні об'єкти от з
огляду на Отакі заяви чи не думаєте Ви
що комунікаційна політика церковного
питання за кордоном провалилася звідки
беруться такі заклики такі думки за
кордоном Я думаю що є певний нерозуміння
процесів які відбуваються в Україні і ми
чітко відділяємо релігійні питання реп
питання свободи совісті і питання
управління майном а те той факт що
значні об'єкти вагомі об'єкти культурної
спадщини належать державі не є
виключенням Європі нотр-дам належить
державі те саме ми говоримо про Україну
але той факт що багато років закривалися
очі на
неналежне управління державним майном
під час війни Вони постало занадто
гостро а й держава має на себе перебрати
адекватне управління це не говорить про
те що духовне життя у лаврі завершиться
Ні воно буде продовжуватися верхній
Лаврі проводять служби в тому числі
представники пцу в нижній Лаврі
продовжується Релігійне життя УПЦ ммп
ніхто їм в цьому не заважає тому тут
жодного втручання з боку держави в
релігійні справи не існує інша справа що
рпц надзвичайно активна завдяки тому що
це є інструментом пропагандистської І я
б сказав навіть військовий машини Кремля
надзвичайно активний за кордоном з
огляду на його такою поєднання чи
згрозшення з кремлівської владою і
своїми листами своїми позиціями
намагається вплинути на точку зору
представників інших релігійних
організацій але оскільки українська
держава діє до досить коректно
толерантно прозоро в цьому в цих
питаннях я думаю що чим далі тим менше
питань буде уникати які порушення
виявила комісія мінкульту в Лаврі йшлося
про незаконну забудову добудову
неналежне утримання майна Які найбільш
кричущі порушення наскільки я пам'ятаю
там Потрібно подивитися в документи які
в тому числі відправлялися у пцнта це
відсутність документів відповідних
дозволів на певні забудови неналежне
утримання майна Ну напевно це дві
ключові два ключових моменти
[музика]
порушена там 15 чи 16 з будівлі нових це
будинки в тому числі так би мовити
резиденції очільників цих Церков
в тому числі якісь гаражі склади
крамнички Тобто там таке бурхливе
економічне життя відбулось і
коли представники упцнп жаліються з
приводу того що в них щось не забирають
шановне панство це належить державі
держава повертає в управління те що
належить державі приватного їхнього
майна там немає
оці набудови потрібно з'ясовувати їхні
статуси і в подальшому з юридичної точки
зору
вирішити питання їхнього там або
використання або
ну статусу яким чином у нас є план щоб з
ними робити але зараз сказати не буду
будуть передаватися в користування пцу
наразі перед нами стоїть питання
оновлення взагалі сенсів і змісту Лаври
ми не ведемо зараз розмову з приводу
негайної передачі пцу але те що той факт
що там може служити представники
пцу і в подальшому буде види дивитися на
розвиток ситуації з УПЦ МП яким чином
вони трансформують свої
[музика]
легальний статус на території України Я
думаю що продовження служіння і монахів
і священиків Лаврі безпечно буде чому
зараз вхід у лавру дозволений з 9 до 18
години
тому що на жаль УПЦ МП використовує
ситуацію з дефекту контролем над значною
частиною нижньої Лаври хоча заповідник
перебрав на себе управління ще десятьма
об'єктами вже перебрав для того щоб на
території нижньої Лаври заходили якісь
незрозумілі люди які теоретично видають
себе за паломників ким вони є Ми не
розуміємо і оскільки є перешкоджання
діяльності комісії коли виникають з
кущів
люди з невідомим статусом ну це
принаймні обмеження
можливових провокативних дій з боку
тих хто не є священниками тих хто не є
монахами А є людьми які якимось чином
потрапляють на територію нижньої Лаври
там же поліція стоїть біля входу
перевіряє документи перевіряє транспорт
саме тому з 9 до 18:00 то служіння там
продовжується Ну це ж нічний час так би
мовити фактично
таке обмеження дозволяє уникати
імовірних провокацій чи не є це
обмеженням прав і свободвір'ям абсолютно
ні служба відбувається в тих церквах які
належать державі держава зазвичай
домовляється з релігійними організаціями
про часи служіння
це нормальна практика яке майбутнє
Київської духовної академії семінарії
не знаю
ви кажете що чернече життя в Лаврі
продовжуватиметься
богослужіння триватимуть коли держава
вже перебере на себе всі права там по
користуванню майном що буде з
семінаристами це навчальний заклад
це навчальний заклад УПЦ
тобто вони підлягають виселенню ні Я
цього не казав
я казав
дивіться якби був діалог то тоді б в
межах цього діалогу Можна було б
говорити про певні плани наразі їхнє
знаходження на території нижньої Лаври
має бути або трансформоване або зупинене
але бо в жодному разі ми не
застосовуємо якихось насильницьких
діячів спонукання до того щоб їх звідти
виселяти буде діалог буде закон
новий і в межах цього закону будемо
діяти
яким чином ви бачите ось той день коли
УПЦ МП представники УПЦ МП повністю
залишають територію заповідника
києво-печерська лавра А ми не знаємо чи
будуть вони на той момент представниками
УПЦ МП чи якоїсь іншої релігійної
організації
У нас є концепція яку ми обговорювали в
тому числі з фахівцями ми обговоримо ще
з громадськістю трансформації Лаври
цього року найближчі три роки середнього
терміново і найближчі кілька років до
тисячолітнього ювілею самою Лаври цього
року здається буде 950 років в
Успенському собору тобто
план дій поступового оживлення
існування
і нижній і верхньої Лаври які б існували
як єдине ціле у нас існує і в межах
нього передбачається
продовження духовного і чорничого життя
ну Але для того щоб щось там почати
якесь об'єднання верхнє нижньої Лаври
треба я так розумію спершу щоб УПЦ МП
залишили приміщення храми І у вас був
вільний е-е процесу багатошаровим
по-перше і тривають судові рішення які
наразі Практично всі на користь
заповідника чи Міністерство друге ми
очікуємо прийняття закону третє який би
не який це все ж таки діалог з
представниками монастиря який
знаходиться на території нижньої Лаври і
всі ці процеси рано чи пізно мають
пройти до
спільного знаменника
представники УПЦ МП знають про ось цю
вашу концепцію щодо трансформації Лаври
Я знаю що представники заповідника з
дикими з деякими монахами і деякими
священниками це обговорювали навряд чи
вони обговорювали це з керівництвом
монастирів
А коли у пацієнта залишить територію
Лаври спитайте у пацієнта
ви навіть не беретеся припускати скільки
часу можуть зайняти суди за Я ж казав це
три Ну ще не менше три шари діалог закон
суди суди можуть тривати ще певний час
діалогу немає
в будь-якому разі діалог на низовому
рівні між представниками монастиря і
заповідника триває це робочий діалог
люди живуть поруч комунікують є якісь
спільні питання які вони вирішують
наразі немає діалогу і порозуміння з
керівництвом пацієнта не релігійні
питання
[музика]
з приводу дубляжу іноземних фільмів
українською мовою виникло дуже багато
суперечок Це ось ідея так відмовитись
від українського дубляжу вона
насторожила із сферу яка цим займається
і кінотеатр який так потерпають від того
що в них мало відвідувачів ви
підтримуєте Наскільки я розумію
впровадження англійської мови на різних
рівнях і в освіті і в культурі Як ви
бачите вихід із цієї ситуації яка
склалася з кіношниками із кінотеатрами
як це все буде вирішуватися в
майбутньому Ну по-перше я хотів би
сказати що закон значно ширший ніж
використання той чи іншої мови в
кінотеатрах він в першу чергу робить
акцент на освіті на те щоб з дитячого
садочку запроваджувалися виховні часи
англійською мовою те саме в школах те
саме на щодо курсів вивчення
умови дорослими людьми і на мій погляд
Це абсолютно прогресивний крок тому що
країна яка довгий час була білінгвальною
там російсько-українська з часом і це не
буде завтра це буде з часом
може бути так само як багато країн в
Європі біля навального англійською і
українською стосовно конкретної історії
з кінотеатрами Ми з зустрічалися з
представниками кіномереж здається на
мацало так би мовити варіант порозуміння
Я думаю що в подальшому в результаті
обговорення з депутатами тому що це ж
лише проект
знайдемо
консенсусне рішення принаймні ми
говорили про такий елемент як ринкове
регулювання
але зараз обговоримо деталі Я думаю що
після цього
всі так би мовити тривоги які
висловлювали громадськість буде знято
ранкового регулювання що ви маєте на
увазі в команді
таке ранкове регулювання існує багатьох
країнах Європи
Тобто це з одного боку бажання кінотеатр
все ж таки ти назустріч загальній
концепції того що англійська мова
підніме свій статус в Україні станом
мовою міжнародного спілкування з іншого
боку
якась допомога з боку держави того щоб
кінотеатри не зазнали суттєва втрат
стосовно дубляжу зараз
50-60% до пляжу здійснюється в Україні
для OTT платформ лише там 40 чи 50
здійснюється для кінотеатрів але це
питання також має бути ринковим способом
врегулювання
Тобто ви не вважаєте що потрібно щоб всі
іноземні фільми в кінотеатрах йшли з
субтитрами без дубляжу з того що ми
чуємо і від громадськості від депутатів
і від представників кінотеатрів
всі схиляються до того що треба знайти і
описати модель ринкового регулювання а
не обов'язково всіх фільмів то більше що
навіть в проекті закону там було
передбачено здається
що спочатку 50% потім 75 тощо але скоріш
за все в результаті діалогу ця формула
зазнає змін
Київрада заборонила використання
російськомовного контенту в Києві музики
книжок ваше ставлення до цього і
наскільки ефективний цей крок у столиці
якщо не передбачено жодної
відповідальності за порушення
Я думаю що найкраща відповідь наша на цю
історію це створення Українського
контенту нам потрібно створювати
українські контент тому що в лідерах
користування Ютубу ви можете часто
Навіть зараз побачити російський контент
натомість створення Українського
контенту як аудіо так і аудіовізуального
літератури
має
набагато більший ефект
ніж декларативні заяви якщо там дійсно
не передбачено жодної відповідальності у
нас існує закон про мову у нас є ціле
уповноважений по мові з своїми
регуляторними спроможнями Навіщо
приймалося це рішення Мені важко сказати
тому що всі інструменти так би мовити
контролю з цим процесом в державі вже
існують ще один скандал Який Ось
Минулого тижня збурив громадськість коли
Верховна Рада проголосувала за
те що виділити 570 мільйонів гривень на
добудову музею голодомору плюс згадали
ще й про те що виділилися мільйони
гривень на створення новорічних комедії
на телеканалі дом це все дуже обурило
людей Бо виникло питання а чому це
витрачаються такі гроші на музей на
новорічній комедії а не витрачаються на
закупівлю тих самих Дронів для
військових
ваша позиція в цьому питанні чи доречно
витрачати гроші навіть приватні Кошти
які ми зібрали для того щоб змінити
радянський герб
на батьківщині матері на тризуб теж
виникли запитання Чому Міністерство
культури ми збирали кошти на дрони
I am sorry very much ну кожен займається
своєю справою це перше друге це приватні
кошти компанії які дуже відомі в Україні
які вже зібрали купу грошей і на дрони і
на допомогу ЗСУ на допомогу лікарям
стосовно питання про контенти щойно про
це говорив це надзвичайно важливо в
конкурсі брали участь десятки компаній
і це не новорічній комедії не знаю хто
знайшов новорічну комедію На 90% це
твори присвячені
сучасним подіям в Україні і коли
російська держава витрачає десятка сотні
мільйонів доларів
на створення цього контенту який в тому
числі потрапляє в Україну а Україна
українська держава виділяє досить
незначну суму порівняно з агресорами на
створення україномовного Українського
контенту який буде доступний для широкої
громадськості буде показаний на різних
телеканалах України
і фокусується питання
знову у нас рада давайте спочатку
розберемося з деталями перше ніж кричати
вовки
стосовно музею голодомору
ми маємо завершити його будівництво хоча
б річницю
90 річницю відзначення цієї події так би
мовити на жаль трагічної події яку
визнають вже геноцидом багато
парламентів світу а на жаль у нас
довгобуд досі недобудований якщо його
недобудувати ми не добудуємо ніколи Тому
що у процесі будівництва є свої рамки
правила якщо стоїть недобут він починає
руйнуватися навіть ті Кошти які
вкладалися
за різних
каденції різних так би мовити прем'єрів
президентів тощо будуть витрачені дарма
але ж питання будівництва під час війни
Коли на Київ щодня ледь не щодня летять
ракети летять дрони ну таке спірне
питання тобто це все може бути
зруйноване в одну мить те що вкладаються
Кошти які можливо могли бути витрачені
там на відновлення житла для людей так
само як і відновлення зруйнованих
пам'яток культури можна сказати що ця
драма витрачання коштів ми знаходимо
донорів і знаходимо в тому числі західно
фінансування на відновлення зруйнованих
церков на відновлення зруйнованих
бібліотек на відновлення зруйнованих
музеїв на перекриття того тих дахів які
так би мовити потрібно перекрити для
того щоб їх зберегти Давайте скажемо про
це Що це не потрібно робити і Давайте
тоді скажемо За що ми воюємо воюємо з
нашою ідентичність з на шу спадщину за
нашу мову літературу історію і саме
спадщину і відображенням того За що ми в
тому числі виявимо Вона має спадщини
немає і людей і важливо що зазначити що
ми не можемо використовувати кошти
держбюджету які
призначені вірніше у нас
Кошти які збирає українська держава
ідуть на армію
ці кошти про які ми зараз говоримо це
кошти для відновлення далі продовження
функціонування Української держави і ці
кошти які визначені для відновлення чи
завершення будівництва на військо Ми не
можемо використовувати
100% не можна використати ці кошти на
дрони Але можливо можна використати на
відбудову житла вони використовуються в
тому числі і не відбудову житла
ці кошти які пішли на музей вони вже не
використаються не відбудову житла
тоді повернемось до того питання про яке
я сказав Та де Давайте тоді визначимось
суспільством що зберігати українську
спадщину історію під час війни ми не
будемо скажіть про це Чому в голосуванні
дії всі голосують за необхідні заміни
Горба а потім починають говорити про те
що приватні кошти зібрані на це не на
часі Їх потрібно було збирати на Дрон
Давайте будемо послідовними визначиться
і скажіть не будемо паритись тоді пане
Олександре Дякую вам за цю розмову